let's talk about this this story right
here we got this from timcast.com quebec
pulls proposed tax on unvaccinated
canadians premier francois le gold cited
today cited a desire to maintain social
cohesion in his announcement on february
1st i have to wonder what that might
mean i mean that's that's incredible it
means become ungovernable exactly well
this is sort of what we were talking
about the other day when i was saying a
huge reason this trucker convoy is a
threat to them is because people realize
they can stand up for themselves and
don't have to obey every order they're
not going to be as effective when they
try i mean like people have power or
yeah exactly what does that mean the
people have all the power whoa whoa you
mean like workers of the world are
united
no no not like that right right right i
think it's funny that i've pointed out
you know we've talked about
there's like a meme about whenever
workers actually do start protesting but
it's for like the wrong direction the
left gets mad about it and it's never
been exemplified better than it is now
with truckers workers of the world
uniting in opposition to government
authoritarianism
and now they're all getting angry about
it but but but the point is
the point of this story is
to maintain social cohesion yeah it's
working
it's it's it's having an impact when
people stand together and push back and
honk their horns
the powers that be recoil and fear i
mean i just love seeing these these
comments where you know so it's it's
like somebody's screaming i just can't
take it anywhere you know these are
these racist whites and families here
they're in there in the downtown and
right over there and then you just and
the response is just honk
honk yeah you know this reminds me in
china when they took this app off young
people's phone
to have like a basically funny stuff and
talk about their private
you know sex and dating
and the government even banned that app
and how did they protest it to find our
own people they go out and
diddy diddy they pushed their car diddy
really is like hey friend hey hey
comrade diddy diddy
was the name of the app right
no it was like the the car noise did you
also use the app right the name of the
app was dd yeah right they
yeah they did it was
like so they were blocking the horns to
make it sound like dd it sounds like
indeed
against the government who took away
people's entertainment so that's that
tells you the state of today's young
people in china
they're just they have no meanings in
life i don't i don't know if it was you
posted it jack someone posted george
soros getting angry about what china was
doing and speaking out against him was
it was it you tweeted about that uh brie
dale had tweeted it and then i i'd
comment
someone said that soros is finally
realizing yeah that was me yeah the west
is going to be subservient to china in
this you know after this great reset or
whatever right so and you're seeing this
like jake taper at cnn is now attacking
china during the olympics and george
soros was out and come out and put this
video and so people are saying hey wait
what's going on like why you know why
why is soros the guy who's mr open
society mr color revolution you know
who's spread so much misinformation
actual discord means the guy funded all
these crazy da's across the united
states that lets violent criminals out
in the on the streets and that's why
homicides are to complete um record
highs just across the country but
suddenly he's against the ccp what's
this and i said like no guys this is
game of thrones stuff right this is
stuff that's going on at the higher
level it's who gets to be senior partner
who get to be junior partner and the
idea was the west thought they were
going to be the senior partners but
suddenly they realized that if all the
manufacturing is in another country then
guess what
that country's the one with the power
you know i almost can't believe that's
the reason because how stupid do you
have to be
for you know for for these the these
these industrialists these wealthy
individuals these global leaders to
outright be like no no it's fine if we
move our manufacturing to china it's a
good thing and now they hold all the
cards and they're like uh okay maybe
that was a bad thing do you remember
when republicans when so trump used to
talk about this and this was one of the
singular issues i think two of his
biggest issues immigration and china
right we're like two of the absolute
biggest ones and both of them revolve
around the concept of sovereignty but on
those focused issues he really changed
the conversation on and i remember when
he started coming out and saying
we need to have steel tariffs because
the steel industry is a matter of
national security in the united states
there were so many of these like
libertarian type conservatory and
republicans say what do you mean what
what does that have to do with national
security that's just that's just the
steel industry and we should have uh you
know the free flow of capital and goods
and people across borders and the free
you know free trade is really what
matters and he turns around and said
yeah well what if we get into a war with
china and we can't make steel to build
equipment for our military what if
there's a global pandemic and we can't
make vitamin c oops or antibiotics right
right that's why it's more than national
security it's a matter of knife and
death if you rely on them
so now you say they had the ppe mask
diplomacy right and they use that and
now you know next don't know what they
use and now they're probably everybody
too
so we uh you lily you actually lived
under the you know communism in in china
now i'm curious uh since we've had last
had you on there's been a lot of
developments with the vaccine mandates
and all that stuff i'm curious what your
thoughts are on all of it and the
similarities
well i'm so encouraged by this uh
trucker's freedom convoy that's like i
have never seen canadians
are so excited about their country we
saw canadian social this country i have
been telling people the vaccine passport
have a qr code on your cell phone
it would be just like china's social
critic system they'll track you long
stop 24 hours a day wow you have no
pricey privacy well i haven't seen this
one guy showed me in las vegas his qr
code on his cell phone from saudi arabia
he said lily i have to have three shots
in order to travel to las vegas for
business i said well how how do you show
them the papers i show you he showed me
his qr code on his cell phone i said
that looks like china's cell phone
social criticism you have been tracked
24 hours a day he said what choice do i
have so i'm telling people in this
country with some word if you let them
to do that
it's under view basic human freedom it's
it's black mirror it's a how how have we
made a tv show about this and now we're
it's not even been a couple of years and
we're already yes exactly i have uh uh
friends of friends stories i've heard
about people who are currently traveling
around in china and it's like oh yeah
you have to scan everything to get in
any everywhere you've got you've got to
be completely up to date and then to get
into any building it's scanned and all
tracked everywhere you go well for
um for beijing olympics which are coming
down they're locking down so they have
to be very careful about this because
they don't want to lock down beijing
itself and so the olympic star what in
two two or three days i think and three
days and
they're locking down various districts
of beijing but they're not actually
locking down the main centers yet now
they have this thing called the bubble
or if you're in they call it being in
the loop when you come in but they're
even with because they're pursuing the
zero covet strategy even with that
they've had breakthrough cases inside
that bubble so what are they doing if
you're anywhere near there if a single
case comes out they will lock you down
inside a shopping mall they're locking
down entire office buildings so for how
long
until everyone tests negative
zero zero coffee you're gonna go so
you're trapped in a mall for like two
weeks so whatever it is wow you're just
locked in there i'm not surprised they
were welding people's doors precisely
yeah i don't know why ilc would not
delay it or changing location
and they also change the human rights
rules that they want to apply to you
know paris to other places but not to
beijing there's a lot of questions
needed to be raised what is ioc doing in
beijing now with all their strict zero
covey lockdowns well are the athletes
going to protest it and bail out or
right or are they just going to go along
with it i haven't seen any athletes
protesting yet because i and i remember
too like go back and look at um the rio
olympics which were just a couple of
years ago and when zika virus was going
on and i remember olympi you know a lot
of athletes saying hey i'm not going to
go to rio because i don't want zika
right well we're seeing the exact same
thing with the omicron olympics but to
answer your question what's up with the
ioc i mean it's it's pretty simple and
this is what i actually wrote about in
newsweek and nbc's get you know sending
out this this uh hitman to come after me
um is that
you're you i've heard people describe
the relationship as something like elite
capture like the ccp has captured
american elites but it's not like that
it's actually elite merger that's what
we're seeing across the world and so yes
there's this argument over who gets to
be senior partner and who gets to be
junior partner but at the end of the day
this has been a merger that's been in
place for almost 30 years now certainly
with since their ascension to the wto
and that's why when you see these things
like hunter biden's laptop or the fact
that barbara boxer the former senator
from california is now a registered
agent of a ccp surveillance company
which actually makes the cameras for
xinjiang right i mean you could go look
all this stuff up but can you say it
like alex jones now
all right right well you see uh
years they're 30 years they've been
setting us up they've been selling us
out they've been sitting there they're
sitting out selling out your children
they're gonna be hooked up to the ccp
machines
it's funny because when you talk about
uh you know you have what is that
picture of klaus schwab holding the
great reset book or something right the
media told us it's a conspiracy theory
there's no great reset and he's like
smiling with us but he wrote the book
it's just so insane how
the i gotta say it does feel like we're
winning when you get stories like the
truckers pushing back them starting to
back down it they
they couldn't pull off what they thought
they could pull up
what i mean by that they i mean like
these authoritarian political
establishment elite types but you know
it'll come next right just you just wait
give it this like a couple of more days
of the trucker protests and you're
immediately going to see the media flood
the zone mark my word screenshot this
whatever i know we're live um
you will see the media pushing stories
about self-driving trucks very very soon
as a response to all of this yeah
suddenly and like i'm because yang
talked about this a lot and you're gonna
say oh no it'll be so great and they
won't get an accident and time will you
know they will travel faster because
they don't have the time restrictions
that truckers have etcetera that's the
next thing that's coming thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you